-What is this?
-What does it look like, dummy?
It's a bridge of spies.
Go away.
We're spying.
-I want to test you a little
bit, you know, see what you got.
-You got it. Bring it on.
-So I was thinking maybe
you could perform a few scenes
from "Bridge of Spies"
for us right now.
How does that sound?
-Challenging but fun.
Let's do it.
-That'd be fun?
Now, here's the catch --
the scenes are not from
the actual movie.
They were all written by
elementary school kids.
We gave them no direction,
just the title
"Bridge of Spies."
Alright, here we go.
It's time for "Kid Theater."
Here we go.
-♪ Kid Theater ♪
♪ Kid Theater ♪
-Alright.
This first one,
here's your script.
-Thank you very much.
-No problem.
This one is from Chris.
He's 8 years old.
You'll be playing
the role of spy.
-Yes.
-And I will be playing
the role of man.
-Okay.
-Higgins will read the scene
descriptions for us.
Higgins, set the scene, please.
-There was once a bridge
that was full of spies.
A man walked up to it.
-What is this?
-What does it look like, dummy?
It's a bridge of spies.
Go away.
We're spying.
-Can I be a spy?
-No.
This bridge is too full of spies
already.
There's not room for any more.
-Who are you spying on?
-Each other.
-How?
-You sure ask a lot of questions
for someone who is not a spy.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe I am a spy.
-Are you?
-No.
-Are you sure?
-The man rips off his mask.
-You are a spy!
-Exactly!
And you fell for my trick.
Therefore you are
no longer a spy.
Hahahahaha!
-Hahahahaha!
[ Applause ]
-What are you laughing at?
-Nothing. I just wanted to
keep acting like a spy.
-And scene.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is a very --
-That is a nice one.
-You're keeping that one?
-That deserves a second look.
I think it really does.
-This is the second one here
for you.
-Let's see what this one is.
-This is sent in by Jack.
He is 7 years old.
For this one, I'll play Joe,
and you'll play
the role of Margaret.
-Let me adjust my --
Alright, I am now Margaret.
-You are Margaret and I am Joe.
Okay, Higgins, will you set
the scene for us, please?
-Margaret walks up to Joe
on the sidewalk.
-Hi, Joe!
-Hey, Tim! I mean Margaret!
[ Laughter ]
-Joe, how do you get me
and your brother mixed up?
We've been going out
for eight years!
-Sorry, you kind of look alike.
-Anyway, did you hear about
the new bridge?
-What bridge?
-You know! The bridge of spies!
-No! What the heck is that?
-Well, I'll tell you...
-Wait!
-What?
-Okay, never mind.
I thought you were Tim
for a second.
[ Laughter ]
Tell me about the new bridge.
-Well, they're gonna build
this new bridge
somewhere in China or something,
and they're gonna call it
the bridge of spies
'cause they are finding spies
and taping them together
to make a bridge.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! That's gonna take
like a hundred years!
-Yeah!
They didn't have enough wood,
so they're gonna use spies.
-What do the spies think of it?
-I don't know the spies, Joe.
-Sorry for asking, Tim.
-I'm not your brother,
I'm Margaret!
-Want to get dinner?
-Yes. Cake, please.
-And scene.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Think about it. Think about it.
I'll take that one.
-You want that one?
Take another look at that.
-I'll take another look
at that one.
-A little polish on that,
a little rewrite.
-And I'll get it back to you.
This last one here,
this is the last one,
sent in by Luke.
He's 7 years old.
Thank you for sending these in.
Tom, you'll be playing Spy #1.
-Spy #1.
-And I'll be playing Spy #2.
-Alright. Spy #1.
-Higgins, set the scene, please.
-Two spies stand on a bridge.
One of them has a pair
of binoculars.
-I can see bad guys
coming in the distance.
-I wish I could see them too,
but you're the one
with the binoculars.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not my fault
you forgot yours at home.
-It kinda is. You told me
we wouldn't need them today!
-I was joking!
We always need them.
We're spies!
-Obviously! But we're also
friends, so I trusted you!
-You should never trust a spy!
-But what about trusting...
a friend spy?
-Spy 1 and Spy 2
look at each other.
Spy 1 looks amazed.
-Wow.
I never thought about it
like that before.
Maybe friendship is more
important than spying.
-Exactly.
-Here.
You can have my binoculars.
[ Audience "awws" ]
-Spy 1 hands over the binoculars
to Spy 2.
-Ha! You're such a loser.
Rule number one of being a spy
is never hand over
your binoculars!
-You tricked me.
You're a good spy
and I'm a bad spy.
-You're right. I'm the best
and you're the worst.
-Uh-oh. The bad guys are here!
We have to fight them now!
-But we're both
terrible fighters!
-Quick, throw the binoculars
at them!
-Spy 2 throws the binoculars
at the bad guy
and hits him in the face.
The bad guy falls.
Spy 1 puts his arm around Spy 2.
-We did it!
We saved the world.
Let's go get lunch
and talk about our friendship.
-And scene.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic.
That's what I call acting chops.
-That goes away.
-That's the one.
That's the one right there.
Tom Hanks!
I want to test you a little bit,
you know?
I want to see what you got.
-Alright.
-So I was thinking
maybe you could perform
a few scenes from "Birdman"
for us right now
and we could see how good
your performance is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Does that sound --
Does that sound cool?
-So you're kind of --
you want to test me.
-Yeah. Yeah, is that cool?
-I ain't afraid of you, bitch,
so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a fun game.
We're playing a fun game
together.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Here's the catch.
The scenes that you'll be
reading are not
from the actual movie.
-Okay.
-They're all written by
elementary school kids.
We gave them no direction.
We just gave them the title.
And we asked them
to write a scene
based on what they think a movie
called "Birdman" would be about.
-Uh-huh.
-Do you want to do this?
I'm gonna read them with you.
-I ain't afraid of you, bitch.
-Alright, let's go.
Let's do it.
Time for "Kid Theater."
Here we go.
-♪ Kid Theater ♪
♪ Kid Theater ♪
-Alright, here we go.
This first one here is from --
this is from Connor.
He's 7 years old
from New York City.
-What part am I playing?
-Alright, you will be playing
Birdman.
-Oh, okay.
-Okay, good.
I will be playing the role of
the baseball hitter.
-Oh, okay.
-The baseball hitter.
-This is from Connor.
-Yes.
Higgins will read our scene
directions, descriptions for us.
Higgins, please set the scene.
-This story takes place
on a baseball field.
The best baseball team is losing
and the best hitter needs help.
-Oh, no.
I need to hit a home run.
Someone please help.
-Did someone say help?
I am here.
-Wow, it's Birdman!
I thought you were not real.
-I am real
and I am here to help you!
Do you need power
to hit a home run?
-Yes, please.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. All you need to do...
[ Cheers and applause ]
All you need to do...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
...is touch my beak.
-The hitter touches his beak.
Beak.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
I'm gonna hit a home run now.
Thank you, Mr. Bird!
-No problem. If you have wings,
you can do anything.
-Where can I get wings?
-[ Chuckles ] Target or Walmart!
[ Laughter ]
-And scene! There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Target or Walmart.
-[ Laughs ]
-These are fantastic.
-That was great.
The next one here --
Here you go. This is for you.
-Thank you.
-This next one
is sent in by John.
He's 7 years old.
He's from Dallas, Texas.
Michael, once again,
you'll be playing Birdman.
-Okay.
-I'll be playing
the role of Thomas.
Higgins, set the scene.
Let me get in character.
-A little boy meets
his favorite superhero
for the very first time.
[ Laughter ]
-Birdman! Is that you?!
-Caw! Caw! Caw!
[ Laughter ]
-If you don't get this Oscar,
man, I'm telling you --
I mean, this is like --
I always believed in you,
Birdman.
I am your number-one fan.
-Caw! Caw! Caw!
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
I want to be just like you
when I grow up, Birdman.
[ Laughter ]
-Caw! Caw! Caw!
-I --
I wish my dad was here
to meet you too.
-He is.
Wow.
-Where?
-I am your dad, Thomas.
-I knew it, Birdman Dad.
-No, you didn't.
-You're right.
Can you call me --
[ Laughter ]
Can you call me Bird Son?
-No. Your name is Thomas.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And scene.
One more.
Alright, the last one.
Let's do one more. Here you go.
-Okay.
These are unbelievably great.
-This is the last one.
-These are actual kids, right?
-How cute, man.
Let's do one more.
This last one --
-You want to do Birdman?
-Yeah.
-You want to play him?
-I'll play --
I'd love to play Birdman.
-You got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, here we go.
Did we say who this is from?
This is from Duncan.
He's 6 years old from
West Orange, New Jersey.
Duncan. Higgins?
-Ready?
Things aren't going good
in the city,
but here comes Birdman to help.
-I'm the Birdman
here to save the day.
I just saved your life.
What's your name?
-My name is Birdwoman.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! I love you, Birdwoman.
You should be my bird wife.
-Okay.
-We'll be a team that fights
bad guys together.
Birdman and Birdwoman.
-Birdwoman and Birdman.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever you say, Birdwoman.
We're married now.
-This is great.
-Let's protect the galaxy!
-I love you.
-And scene right there.
I felt that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I call acting chops.
Thank you to Michael Keaton.
[ Cheers and applause ]